Усе це просто фейк? На цьому відео українські актори
нібито інсценують напад Росії на мирне населення в Україні.
Принаймні так стверджує посольство Росії
в Мадриді у своєму "твіттері".
"Якщо звірств російських військових нема, їх треба вигадати", - йдеться у твіті.
Відео стало вірусним і набрало понад мільйон переглядів.
Але що насправді показано у відео?
Насправді це зйомки фільму. Але не про те, про що каже російське посольство.
Це актори, які знімають сцени
для українського військового фільму "Область Героїв".
Зйомки проводилися серед іншого в Гостомелі.
Ми знайшли кадри зі зйомок,
а сам ролик – зі знімального майданчика,
як нам підтвердив продюсер фільму.
Тобто тут знімають не фейк, а кіно.
А твіт російського посольства в Мадриді згодом видалили.
Поки війна в Україні триває, на іншому фронті
розгортається інформаційна війна. Росія націлена на національну
та міжнародну аудиторію за допомогою масштабної
пропагандистської кампанії, яка працює на різних рівнях.
Давайте розглянемо кілька прикладів.
Для початку: на російському державному телебаченні
в прайм-тайм депутат російської Думи
Олександр Бородай стверджує:
Це брехня. Польща неодноразово заперечувала такі заяви.
Такий крок мав би вагомі наслідки.
Це означало б, що Польща - а, отже, й НАТО -
вступили у війну, ознаменувавши значну ескалацію.
Речник міноборони Польщі у відповідь на запит DW
написав: "Це абсурдні фейкові новини".
Росія натомість не надала жодних достовірних доказів того,
що польські підрозділи воюють в Україні.
Всі докази, які вони представили, були підробками.
Як-от цей начебто наказ верховного генерала польської армії
про мобілізацію. Декілька міжнародних фактчекерів
зробили висновок: це фотошоп.
Російська пропаганда аж ніяк не спрямована лише на те,
щоб впливати тільки на російське населення.
Багато фейків орієнтовані на міжнародну аудиторію.
Давайте розглянемо цей вражаючий приклад:
Це нібито відео DW News розповідає про "злочинного біженця з України",
який, мовляв, шантажував жінок.
"Петро Савченко" буцімто шантажував десятки німкень.
На відео стверджується, що він опублікував
"порнографічні знімки" жінок, зроблених прихованою
камерою після знайомства у барах.
Однак: відео про ймовірного біженця-злочинця - фейк.
Використаний шрифт не відповідає стандартам дизайну DW.
Можна помітити різницю, подивившись на літеру "X".
Також підозріло: ім’я "Петро Савченко" не знаходить
відповідних результатів при пошуку в інтернеті.
Жодне ЗМІ не повідомило про цей нібито інцидент,
що за таких обставин майже нереально.
Речник Федерального управління кримінальної поліції Німеччини
сказав нам, що поліції не відомо про такий випадок.
Та і зворотний пошук зображень показує:
на фотографії зображена інша особа.
Відео зроблено професійно - експерти вважають,
що воно створене російськими фабриками тролів.
Ми досліджували багато речей, які вказують на Кремль,
я маю на увазі, можливо, не сам Кремль, а тих "акторів",
які підтримують Кремль, які працюють на нього –
кремлівські ЗМІ тощо.
Відео, подібні до цього, називаються спуфінгом -
це коли цифрова ідентичність підробляється,
щоб завоювати довіру. Це сталося і з іншими ЗМІ.
Приміром, це відео схоже на продукцію BBC.
Воно стало вірусним після російського ракетного обстрілу
залізничного вокзалу Краматорська в Україні.
У ньому стверджується, що цю ракету українські війська
нібито випустили по своєму ж населенню.
BBC відразу ж заперечила, назвавши відео "фейком".
Продюсер BBC Джо Інвуд, який висвітлював ракетну атаку
для BBC, підтвердив: повідомлення не відповідає дійсності.
Це схоже на спробу вибудувати довіру.
Тож, по суті, канали в Telegram говорять,
що якщо ви не довіряєте нам або не любите російські ЗМІ,
ось BBC говорить вам те саме.
Тож, по суті, це зовнішнє "підтвердження" речей,
які вони намагаються пропагувати та поширювати.
Російська пропагандистська кампанія намагається
виправдати війну та її наслідки перед російською аудиторією,
зображаючи Захід неповноцінним.
І останнім часом помітний зсув до нових тем,
таких як енергетична криза в Європі та санкції проти Росії.
Цей репортаж російського державного телебачення
показує продовольчий банк у Німеччині,
кількість клієнтів якого подвоїлася від початку війни.
Також стверджується, що німці пов'язують
падіння рівня життя із санкціями проти РФ.
Ми знайшли оригінальне відео від Bavarian Broadcasting Company.
У ньому дійсно повідомляється про збільшення попиту
на їжу внаслідок зростання інфляції через війну,
але жодного слова про санкції проти Росії.
Іноді інформацію лише трохи змінено або вирвано з контексту.
Іноді вона цілковито вигадана та абсурдна.
Російський пропагандист розповідає, що зараз Європою
поширюються бактерії, короста, кліщі, блохи і навіть воші,
тому що люди не миються через енергетичну кризу.
Ані на національному рівні, ані в даних Європейського центру
профілактики і контролю захворювань (ECDC) ми не знаходимо
навіть розпливчастих доказів на підтримку
цього абсурдного твердження.
Нам невідомо про значне зростання в ЄС
паразитичних кліщів, вошей і бліх.
Обманювати, заплутувати, маніпулювати –
мета пропаганди перетягнути нас на одну сторону війни.
Однак, мабуть, найбільш цинічне викривлення
цієї війни походить від самого президента РФ.
Однак це твердження різко суперечить дійсності.
Масові вбивства в Бучі, бомбардування пологового будинку
в Маріуполі, використання касетних бомб у Харкові -
список воєнних злочинів проти мирних жителів довгий,
випадки добре задокументовані.
Факти суперечать Путіну.
Проте пропаганда майже завжди досягає однієї мети:
сіє сумніви, роз’єднує та маніпулює.